let's check out shindo uh I wonder if
they've kept it for last cuz it's weird
yeah let's find out I have no clue what
he could have put on just just look at
this be the most all right here we go o
oh oh wow wow this is not what I would
have expected this is not what I oh
God's a lck of [__] up stuff he's got
some [__] good shows here bro all
right so Ghost in the Shell uh JoJo
stardus Crusaders record of lus War
[__] beast G lean Evangelion now
mushishi eslon and Attack on Titan [__]
yeah [__] I [__] with it dude mushishi
and esaf Nas on here so good excuse me G
Lagan as well yeah obviously D I'm not
I'm not counting I'm not counting like
Jojo Gillan a and I very much I I like
he put Ghost in the Shell but Standalone
complex uh which is to me the best ghost
in the showell um so it yeah dude big
props for [__] mashishi though that
that is still in my opinion one of the
most underrated anim the most Joey anime
of all time it is one it's such an
underrated anime it's so good the the
anime equivalent of lighting a
blonde I mean kind of
yeah I I've I've never I've only it's
just going off Clips I've seen of the
show is the equivalent of like it's kind
of more the equivalent of like you know
smoking out of a pipe yeah you're a
little bit fancier no but mushishi is it
I I still think visually it was so
incredibly ahead of its time um and the
story is just so [__] captivating and
it's so good and the manga is amazing as
well yeah it's it's a great show um I
just I it's funny looking back on
mushishi and just like knowing Joey as a
mate I look at mushishi and I'm like
this is this made for me this is
everything that encapsulates Joey as a
vibe in there y you know if if you know
this could be a [__] album cover or
something you know and uh dude mushishi
manga covers our album cover yeah this
so aesthetic what is record I I mean I
know what it is but what is record of
lotus War about record of lotus war is
oh God when did it when did it come out
[__] '90s ' 80s I think it's '90s 990s
right yeah it came
out let me see records of lotus
Wars
1990 okay well I was technically right
what's the show about it's about a Lotus
War isn't it have you seen it I haven't
seen it a long time I don't remember
have you seen it gone I haven't se oh
okay so none of us have seen this so we
yeah I I've heard about the show it's
weirdly I have seen it I remember
nothing about it though St than
you created from the aftermath of the
last great battle of the gods Lotus and
his kingdoms have been plagued by War
for thousands of years as a quiet peace
and unity finally see uh became
foreseeable over the land and unknown
evil being
uh begins to stir an ancient witch has
awakened bent on preserving the island
of lotos by creating political unbalance
throughout the many kingdoms and keeping
anyone from maintaining central control
s like a political there is a certain is
it is it an
isekai no it's just a fantasy fantasy is
it okay are these a political fantasy
because I have seen like uh a lot of it
kind of if it's kind of nostalgic
looking back at a lot of '90s fantasy
cuz the 9s
era of anime did have a lot of fantasy
and funny enough a lot of Isa as well it
was just totally a totally different
vibe than what you see in like the
modern isekai uh landscape right now a
lot of the fantasy back then was about
these kind of like epics and something
more traditional some something more in
line with what you see with like
traditional Jr token kind of like
worldes yeah uh I think one of my
favorites was Three Kingdoms as well
that was a big fantasy that came out as
well what about um obviously what's the
one from the the now and now and then
here and now now and then here and there
um cuz he has another eai Fantasy on
here as well uh I'm not sure I think
this is just a fantasy but escal flon
es people forget that it is an eai it is
technically an eai just totally
different vibe I'm telling you there's
so many eai that came out in the '90s
right it was just it was just totally
different it wasn't seen bottom of the
barrel entertainment it would it was
just more classic kind of like n they
were better at hiding the concept maybe
maybe it's just the people who grew up
with those are now working and the ones
making all these damn stories because
they were so inspired by stuff like esaf
I mean technically you know inashi is an
isaki inashi is an isaki yeah which
everyone
forgets I I think the big difference is
that nowadays isai is used as kind of
like a mechanic to get the main
character somewhere to a fantasy world
and the big difference is that the
protagonist always has no problem being
in the fantasy world but all of the NS e
card that I remember all revolved around
hey how the [__] do I get back home so I
I have the reasonings uh for some of
these which is there any that you guys
want to hear about yeah I would love to
know records of lotus War okay record of
lotus War OG tolken D and Anime that
lives rentree in my soul there we go uh
deed lit is best goal and everybody's
first elf Crush
I'd love to know why JoJo's on there
JoJo's Adventure OST alone makes it one
of the best ever Stardust Crusaders is
my favorite Stone ocean best op barely
beating bloody stream bloody stream is
[__] go bloody bloody bloody stream
isn't Stardust though no bloody stream
is uh battle tendency battle tendency
yeah that is that is the most [__]
hype op yeah all time fight me what
about eSalon
eslon uh isekai before it was cool
okay okay uh fantasy mix great OST uh
fantasy mix he said fantasy mix
twice say no more fantasy Mi mushishi
epitome of anime as Vibe uh characters
are mean characters are so drenched in
sadness I can't help but love them
agreed okay uh NAA naasa uh let's see uh
Peak Miyazaki fantastic storytelling
with great characters amazing and
haunting OST still waiting for a manga
adaptation huh yeah there is a mang
ration isn't there there isn't
apparently oh [__] um evang gallian cuz
he's another person the L would love to
know why Evangel where is it is just
simple how have you felt depression this
series is probably on anybody's top five
a genre in itself perfect mix of
edginess militarism talk out of
nostalgia and emotional trauma askcar
best hell yeah how dare you hell
yeah that's how I knew he was a man of
how could you shinder only anime fans
would be like yeah militarism some deep
topics also this this this girl's best
girl you imagine that just sums up weebs
perfectly but yeah um I'm surprised of
the lack of I guess like you know like
uh sexual shows I am not I am not this
is like the Freer Ren thing where you
know if it's two in your face then a lot
of a lot of like artists or fan artists
that I've seen are just aren't [__]
interested cuz why why would you there's
no imagination there there's no way you
can take you know there's no interesting
thing you can take that character that
hasn't already been presented yeah yeah
he does like he did mention that he
likes what is it like like not looting
but pushing the boundary yeah like
figuring out how to take it further this
is it just does surprise me that the guy
who made metamorphosis likes
mushishi that's just not a combination I
thought would work but I guess I see it
cuz like I I feel like a lot of the
times I you know I'm sure with you as
well talking to like different authors
and what they like sometimes you ask
them what kind of series you're into and
it's never the series you think it's
going to be yeah sometimes the most
[__] up or you know sometimes the
authors that make the most [__] up
stories or sometimes the most like I
remember I remember when shindo was on
the show he said his favorite manga was
spy
family that was kind of which is like
whoa all right good on you I guess yeah
I was talking to uh
oh [__] V like yukimura Yuki makot
yukimura yeah and I was like so why why
do you want to do Vikings and
uh wait let me let me let me let me
remember the name there's this there was
this like Viking cartoon that inspired
him uh and you know inspired him to kind
of like make a viking story outside of
just being
Vikings asterisk is it Vicki Vicki the
Viking can you suchar a Vicky the Viking
or something like that Vicky the Viking
oh yeah animated series and he show me
this [__] and I was like what the
[__] you say what this became mid
Saga this this inspired I have no
enemies what what's next one punch Man
author watch C growing
up bizar like you're like well this is
this is not the vibe I thought he was
going to be that is awesome I love
that I mean he just seems very wholesome
in general though he just seems very
wholesome in general which you know
surprising oh they had a live action
apparently yeah sometimes surprising
when you see these authors that do these
Heavy Deep piercing stories and then
they're like what you so what do you
actually like what do you watch and
they're like oh I like spy family or
like Vicky the vik I'm sure it's fire
I'm sure it's fire so I just like the
fact that Vicki had no enemies
I mean this looks like a show where she
does have no enemies like legit you know
it feels like it's like uh it's like
when you like whenever you find out any
inspiration is so simple you're like
what it's like have you seen that
there's this like short that's going
around it's um I think it's when the one
of the gorillas artists he's saying what
how he got like the starting of um oh
I've seen this yeah and it's the
preset play and it's just the entire
it's the rock one pres you're like what
that's how you can't you didn't even
come that you heard it he just heard
that was like I'm just going to add a
WAP on yeah it was a what is it it's uh
theast clean Eastwood CLE Eastwood this
is clean Eastwood it's like and it's
you're like there's no way there's no
way and it's like same with like death
punk where you find out some of their
some of their songs some the beats are
just straight up just other songs yeah
wasn't it it was like it was like a '90s
Casio keyboard that he bought at a
garage sale and he just like pressed the
rock one and it was literally just CL
it's like so awesome got some Dam Al
yeah when that short became viral I'm
sure some AUD audio engineer somewhere
around the world was like see that's
what I was been saying all of these
years buy out all the Casio keyboards
it's free range oh my God but yeah um
interesting Pico um yeah and uh I guess
great pix around great all around